vegas is a little more wild than usual
this week the 2021 pro bowl riders world
championship is here and rocky is live
outside with some special guests to get
all the details hey rocky whoa okay
sorry jillian
besides lj our pro bull rider and call
me captain our bull we also have flies
so you'll see me swatting a lot but
first things first he's been getting a
little aggressive in there so i feel
like it's time to feed him let's see how
this goes what's the technique here what
do they eat they eat hay they eat grain
right now you just want the hay out of
your hands and
there we go he didn't eat my notes so
that's good that's good all right so lj
let's talk about call me captain who is
he introduce us to the bull call me
captain's a five-year-old pbr buck and
well the pbr is uh known for having the
best of the best and with that being
said we obviously have the greatest bull
riders in in the world but
to have them great rides you got to have
great great athletes on the bull side of
it so
you know he's a these bulls are taken
just like pro athletes i mean they're on
supplements they're getting fed twice a
day they're
they're they're an athlete and we try to
have them the best they can be yeah you
were telling me that bull riding is a
two athlete sport and that's because the
bulls are treated just like the athletes
you guys are both super athletes yeah
the this weekend we're going to pay a
million dollars to the world champion
bull rider and and there's 10 bulls that
are going for bucking bull the year also
so
it's an exciting race on both ends you
know we have fans that are fans of the
writers and we've got fans that are fans
of the bulls more more than a rider so
it's just kind of whatever you like and
it's really neat to see that see the
bulls grow up and
just perform here on the biggest stage
in bull riding
and what's the scoring like i know
because the bulls also get scored during
pbr yeah and in every ride it's it's one
to fifty points uh one to twenty five
for the bull and one to twenty five is
for the rider you know obviously a
perfect score would be a hundred be
fifty and fifty but uh we we actually
broke the the record this year and it
was 96 and three quarters
so hopefully
hopefully we'll see that again with the
world reigning world champion and that
same bull will be here going up for his
world title also that is exciting okay
and tell me what is the atmosphere like
at pbr and why should people come down
and join oh it's uh it's it's fun-filled
family entertainment you're going to be
on the edge of your seat the whole time
you know not only is it a bull riding
you got concerts and you're going to
have big pyro and lights and
like i said a lot of energy is going to
going to be out there because we're
giving away you know millions of dollars
this weekend that is incredible and of
course you got to address the part too i
got my flannel on you got your cowboy
hat on so it's fun to get dressed up and
hang out with the entire family how can
people get tickets they can get them at
the box office or at pbr.com uh
wednesday through sunday sunday's gonna
be the exciting day where they give out
all the money and all the prizes all
right well we are ready to check it in
oh check it out excuse me i will send it
back to you guys i guess we had to feed
him some more huh thank you so much
rocky and here's your chance to win we
are giving away two tickets to the pbr
world finals happening tomorrow through
sunday at t-mobile arena just call eight
now at this number to win tickets and
good luck i'll send it over to jc